hey dr. Burke here in this video I want
to talk about the body types I want to
talk about how to differentiate certain
body types I want to talk about the
cause the underlying cause and some
important tips on each body type so
let's get right into the first number
one is the adrenal body type as you can
see there's a sagging belly now that
belly is fat coming from a hormone
called cortisol it is not necessarily
diet related it is stress related and
that's why when you go on a diet
sometimes it doesn't work until you deal
with the stress part of it and there are
techniques to pull stress out of the
body but I just wanted to point that out
renal cases have problems sleeping they
have problems with a lot of issues with
stress responses feeling calm memory
issues craving for salts and chocolate
the list goes on and on and on but they
mainly have the sagging belly and if you
were to recommend important things the
most important thing is reducing stress
and getting asleep as far as dietarily
they would need to not go on a low
protein diet why because the body is
breaking down more protein instead they
should eat a little more protein with
each meal and they should also have
enough vegetables - given the potassium
they need because they are if it's lots
of stress they'll be depleting the
potassium Reserve and they need that
potassium okay just to get the adrenals
recharged so those are some couple a
couple things with the adrenal now and
number two we have the thyroid body type
now if you look at that type you can see
that the weight is all over not in any
one location
they're just big everywhere but the
thing to know is that if you're
diagnosed with a thyroid problem and the
doctor says you have a thyroid problem
and we just need to give you thyroid
hormones and many times you don't feel
any change or lose the weight then that
is a secondary problem not a primary
problem because again if if someone
diagnosed you with the problem
they give you that thing it should solve
the problem so if it's a secondary
problem you never get better so what
happens what's the primary thyroid a
primary thyroid condition would usually
come from too much estrogen from having
heavy periods or from the environment it
could also come from a lack of digestive
gallbladder release so if your liver is
not doing well and you don't have enough
bile bi le that's a digestive juice that
comes from the liver then you can't
convert t4 to t3 so you can't have those
converting activating hormones in other
words 80% of that thyroid is controlled
by the conversion from t4 to t3 through
the liver and gallbladder if there's a
problem there you won't get the
conversion and then you don't fix that
problem you never fix the thyroid so we
got a high estrogen issue secondly we
have a conversion issue from the liver
and gallbladder and thirdly we could
have a stress adrenal issue which is
right up number one so bad to the point
where let's say youth develop an
autoimmune problem that would be either
Hashimoto's or Graves again these are
just things to ask your doctor and talk
about because a lot of times they don't
look beyond the actual hormone issue so
thyroid issues can even come from the
adrenal because most all autoimmune
cases are stemmed from in caused from
the adrenal and that's why the treatment
for all of them our adrenal hormones
cortisol prednisone that's what they use
in autoimmune
it's a powerful anti-inflammatory it
also is intimately involved with your
immune system so anyway I'm just giving
you tips on what could cause potential
thyroid issues it could be a primary
thyroid but typically there is something
that caused that so we want to look
deeper people just don't one day end up
with a thyroid issue it's triggered by
something okay now what foods should
they eat if it's a thyroid it really
depends on what caused it if it's more
of a gobbler issue they should eat foods
that support the liver if it's a more
estrogen
sure they should eat foods to support
balancing estrogen so it really depends
them again the source of it now number
three this body type down here is the
liver this is mainly seen in men it's a
protruding belly
it's a potbelly but it can also happen
in women as well these cases do not want
to consume alcohol and wine before they
go to bed every night because that
alcohol destroys the liver they also do
not do not do well on heavy protein so
you they do well being a vegetarian with
some small amount of protein but they
need to increase their vegetables
because that is the food that helps the
liver but again we want to find out the
source of where that's coming from
so instead of treating a liver let's
just look at the eating and get the
eating straightened out and support it
that way okay the next body type would
be number four the ovary type the ovary
type holds weight more in the hips and a
little pooch below the belly button that
type is more of an estrogen dominant
case and those cases need to support
estrogen balance well what would that be
well cruciferous vegetables are the key
food to help balance estrogen and also
in their food they want to make sure
that they're not consuming just
commercial food that has hormones in it
they want hormone free type foods
especially dairy and meats and those are
just some general tips on supporting
your body type I hope this helps you
differentiate there's a lot of videos I
have that go into each individual body
type but I wanted to kind of show you
all of them in one short video I'll see
you next video